changing your culture because you're so
driven by a number a goal success is
actually stopping you from getting to
the thing you want attention is the
number one asset we lost as a major
client my head person that runs all of
the New York office which is the biggest
office runs in and when I tell you white
as a ghost I'm talking like Casper the
Friendly Ghost like dead walks in he's
like we lost and we're talking about
eight figures Hefty on my computer I
look up at I'm I'm like okay let's deal
with it later he had come from all these
agencies where like what would have
happened is complete chaos 100 people
would have been laid off blah blah blah
blah blah blah that doesn't come because
my p&l is healthy though it is enough to
absorb it it comes because I'm incapable
of letting business dictate my emotional
Behavior